Have you ever felt so in your stomach that a decision may be wrong or true? But you do not realize why?
Our intuition has always been a mystery related to risk and obsession, but is there a science behind the subject?
Do you have to trust your inner strength?
To understand something immediately without logical thinking has nothing to do with seeing the future and has more to do with identifying patterns.
If this patch shows you a real chess game for five seconds, can you rearrange it?
Studies tell us that most chess beginners can rearrange twenty-five percent of them,
While chess masters can rearrange 95% of them.
But if the test is re-tested completely, both beginners and experts will remember 25 percent of them.
Experts do not have a photographic memory - they simply use their knowledge and intuition
Based on patterns that have passed through years of practice!
Our brain processes information through both slow and rapid thinking as an example,
This exercise will cause stress as a reaction, and your mind will enter the process of slow thinking to solve it,
But this picture requires quick thinking, because understanding feelings of sadness
It is an immediate response of the brain, and there is a sense of rapid thinking.
In a similar study on the game "Shogi" Japanese, asked the contestants to like
The last movement leads to a loss, within one second. With no time for conscious analysis, the brain scan did not appear
Any activity in the cortex in the professional players in the "Shogi", which is responsible for conscious thinking in the brain.
In contrast, the basal contract - part of the brain - is responsible for the formation of habits and spontaneous behaviors.
Interestingly, when it comes to a complex decision as buying a home, many believe
That thinking carefully with a list of pros and cons is the best, but one study actually found that the participants
Choose the best option when they turn to the quick decision,
It turns out that we take into account only a subset of the right information that may lead us to weigh the false significance of each feature.
The study also showed that those who trust his intuition
Was more satisfied with his long-term decision than with those who carefully thought about the process.
However, when you buy simple things like toothpaste
Where diversity is not as complex, studies have found that thought-based decisions are more useful.
Do you think you can recognize your own voice? Amazing that after listening subscribers
In a study of several consecutive recordings including their own voices, seventy-five percent of them made a mistake in distinguishing their own voices,
But the really amazing part is that by measuring the skin's mobility too,
Response levels were higher when they heard their own voice, although they did not consciously distinguish it,
Indicating that they had ignored their inner intuition, which knew the correct answer first.
The phenomenon is repeated in a card game that uses 4 distributions of paper.
Participants choose any card from any group, which may be either good or bad. Without their knowledge
Initially, the first two groups "A" and "B" contain more bad cards, while "c" and "d where good cards more. After selecting ten
Cards The participants had no idea what was going on, but after 50 cards, the majority suspected
Some distributions were better than others. In the end, after 80 cards, they were able to determine
The two groups "A" and "B" were Saitin, and the two groups, "c" and "d" competently, but once again, before we know the idea consciously,
Their skin reaction levels rose early during the first 10 cards in reaction
When approaching group "A" and "B". Their skin was already making unconscious signals about
The correct choice before they do their consciousness, of course, the skin did not realize the correct answer
But their unconscious mind began to understand the pattern before their conscious mind.
If you follow your instincts is always the optimal way? It turns out that it is not the case in cases of sympathy.
It turned out from a study involving more than nine hundred common, that when it comes to interpretation and understanding
Others did the right thing, organized thinking and careful analysis
The information available before making any decision was more successful than relying on the sense of what is true.
Relying on our previous experience is the basic way of how our inner intuition has been, and has helped
Our ancestors distinguish the friend from the enemy. But we gave two systems to think - fast
And slow, we recommend following both.
Special thanks for "audible" for their care of this episode, for an 30-day free trial
audible.com/asap. This day we want to nominate you the book "Khorzmiyat to live by"
It's an exciting look at how computer algorithms can apply to our daily lives
Translation: team translate autrjim @